[Music]
brilliant hello thank you very much it's
my first in-person talk since the
pandemic so it's
quite exciting i feel a bit nervous
okay so one of my summer projects was
finishing editing a collection of essays
on pan psychism with contributions by
scientists as well as philosophers
scientists for example carlo rivelli and
sean carroll and lee smolen and anil
seth who were here
and i was my original plan was to talk
through a lot of these
essays and sort of
discuss them but i realized that would
just take too long so what i've decided
to do is just focus on two critiques of
pan psychism by theoretical physicists
one by uh sabine hussein sabina hussein
felder which wasn't in the volume
actually it was a blog post from a
couple of years ago they got quite a lot
of attention and one that is in the
volume by sean carroll so that's the
first thing i want to do i want to show
how i respond to those critiques show
how i think they don't really
work against psychism in the way they
intend to and then the second part of
thing i want to do towards the end is
just to connect this to broader issues
in the science of consciousness i want
to suggest that the considerations that
come up in responding to these critiques
point the way a possible way forward for
the science of consciousness a way of
overcoming
a deep difficulty at the heart of the
science consciousness that we've been
wrestling with for at least 150 years
and incidentally if anyone's interested
a lot a lot of the vol a a lot of the
essays are already online and i've got a
a link to them all for from my my
horribly titled blog conscience and
consciousness that's a really bad name
but which is also linked to from our
website if anyone's interested
okay so just a quick introduction to pan
psychism we're going to sort of clarify
it more as as a talk goes on but it's
basically the view that consciousness is
a fundamental and ubiquitous feature of
the physical world
doesn't necessarily mean that literally
everything is conscious the basic
commitment is that the fundamental
building blocks of reality perhaps
fundamental particles like electrons and
quarks have incredibly simple forms of
experience and that the very complex
experience of the human or animal brain
is somehow derived from the very simple
experience of the brain's most basic
parts okay so straight on with the
critique so sabina hussenfelder
has argued that
there is inevitably a clash
between pan psychism and the standard
model what is the standard model this is
our best theory of fundamental particles
it postulates 25 particles and
characterizes them in terms of three of
the four known forces electromagnetism
weak and strong nuclear force and
sabina's thought is well look the
standard model characterizes particles
in terms of physical properties like
mass charge spin
if particles also had these
weird
non-physical consciousness properties
presumably that would affect their
behavior and we'd have predictions that
differ from the predictions of the
standard model because the standard
model just predicts their behavior on
the basis of their physical properties
so we'd end up with a clash
the standard model is very well
confirmed so we should reject pan
psychism
okay it's a very intuitive thought i
think
the problem is i think sabina just
misunderstands the view or at least
she's not talking about the kind of pan
psychism that has been much discussed in
contemporary philosophy
which has become known as resilient pan
psychism so cool because it was inspired
by certain things bertrand russell wrote
in the 1920s
so i'd like to talk a little bit more
about this so so
the problem is sabine is thinking of um
pancychism in duelist terms and a lot of
people do think that it's a kind of
natural way so you think like the
electron has its physical properties
like mass and charge and also these
non-physical consciousness properties
but that's not the view of the resilient
panzerkist the view of the russellian
panzykist is that the physical
properties of mass spin and charge
are forms of consciousness that is the
view sounds kind of weird at first how
on earth do we make sense of that so
let's talk a little bit more about spell
out a bit more this resilient panzerkist
view so the starting point russell's
kind of insight was that
physics tells you less than you might
have thought about the nature of reality
in the public mind we have this idea
that physics is giving us this rich
story of the nature of space and time
and matter but actually when you
actually look at the information we're
getting from physics it's really all
about what stuff does
it's about behavior right physics cells
has particles of
mass and spin and charge and these
properties are completely characterized
in terms of what they do
mass is characterized in terms of
gravitational attraction and resistance
to acceleration
charge in terms of traction and
repulsion this is all about what these
properties do in the sense of how they
dispose particles to behave
interesting philosophical question
does this information about the behavior
of mass
tell us anything about the nature of
mass
but another way what is the connection
between the nature of mass and its
behavior well there are broadly speaking
two philosophical camps here
dispositional essentialism represented
for example by barbara vetter here or my
colleague stephen mumford do they think
the nature of mass is just defined by
what it does
once you know everything there is to
know about what mass does you know what
mass is
but an equally popular view
quidditism sounds a little bit harry
potter but don't worry about that
represented by the late great
philosopher king david lewis here uh
according to this view the nature of
mass is not defined by what it does this
view makes a sharp distinction between
what mass does
and what it is
okay so the various arguments back and
forth
uh between these two views i happen to
think the first one is incoherent i've
tried to press a line of argument from
russell
for that but you know we can take them
roughly to be
equal possible metaphysical issue
options
and the panzykist
goes for the quidditis option so the
nature of mass is distinct from its
behavior but if you go for this
quidditis option
there's a question you know what is the
nature of mass we can't look to physics
might sound surprising that you can't
look to physics but physics is just
telling you what it does and on this
view that's distinguished from what it
is so we end up with a kind of gap a
kind of hole in our scientific story of
the universe so the genius of russell in
the analysis of mata in 1927 was to
put consciousness in that hole
right we struggle to find a place for
consciousness in our scientific picture
of the world we've got this hole
maybe we can put consciousness in the
hole
so on the uh the russellian pan psychist
extension of this which is not quite the
view russell hell but it's
closely related
mass just is a very simple form of
consciousness physics tells you what it
does
but in terms of what it is
it's a it's a very elementary form of
consciousness
so on this view when you're doing
physics
you are
studying forms of consciousness you
don't know that's what you're doing
because when you're doing physics you're
just interested in behavior
i i sometimes put it you know when
you're doing physics it's like playing
chess when you're just interested in
what the pieces do you're not interested
in what they're made of
but nonetheless umber knows you that
that is what you're doing so i think
once once we realize that this is what
the view is i think sabine's position
just doesn't hit target because she's
assuming that
you know everything the particle does is
determined by the properties of the
standard model that's what the pan
psychist thinks
right they just have a different
metaphysical philosophical theory of the
nature of those properties they think
they're forms of consciousness
whereas sabine talks about the standard
model sean focuses on the core theory
which is the standard model combined
with the weak field limit of general
relativity so you may know that there's
this difficulty reconciling general
relativity our best theory of big things
and quantum mechanics our best theory of
little things
but as i understand it i'm not a
physicist um
the clash only arises in certain
non-terrestrial circumstances like
inside a black hole or something we have
very high gravity
for the the matter in ordinary in bodies
and brains
we can actually bring quantum mechanics
and general relativity together by just
taking the standard model and the weak
field limit of general relativity so
sean carroll thinks we should have great
confidence that we do now already have
the complete and final
um
physical theory of the matter in bodies
and brains
and then his thought is well look if
consciousness is a fundamental property
having an impact on the brain
this will result in brains doing things
not predicted by the core theory because
the course theory doesn't talk about
consciousness
so it's a bit like sabine's objection
but at the level of brains rather than
particles
okay well in responding to this let's
look at a little bit more detail into
upon psychism
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas